Bonjour à tous, petite vidéo de réaction à chaud
à cette annonce extraordinaire
qui vient d'être faite ce soir
et qui va être publiée demain
dans la revue scientifique Nature.
On vient de découvrir une exoplanète
autour de l'étoile Proxima du Centaure.
Alors Proxima du Centaure,
ce n'est pas n'importe quelle étoile,
c'est l'étoile qui est la plus proche de nous,
après le soleil évidemment.
Elle est située à 4 années lumières,
c'est notre plus proche voisine.
Donc cette exo-planète,
elle est aussi proche que possible.
Et cerise sur le gateau, il semblerait
que cette exo-planète ait des caractéristiques
qui pourraient la rendre potentiellement habitable
et peut être qu'elle pourrait abriter la vie.
En tous cas,
elle aurait les caractéristiques nécéssaires
pour peut-être abriter au moins de l'eau liquide.
Et on va voir exactement ce qu'il faut en penser.
Alors cette planète qu'est ce qu'on en sait ?
Sa masse déjà, c'est une masse qui est comparable
à celle de la Terre
puisque ce qu'on appelle sa masse minimale,
c'est 1.3 fois la masse de la Terre,
donc vraiment une masse du même ordre de grandeur que celle de la Terre.
Et ça c'est très important puisque ça indique
que c'est très certainement une planète rocheuse.
Il faut savoir qu'il y a deux grands types de planètes notamment dans le système solaire.
Il y a les planètes rocheuses :
Mercure, Vénus, la Terre et Mars
qui sont essentiellement faites de cailloux
Et puis il y a les planètes gazeuses,
comme Jupiter, Saturne, Uranus ou Neptune
qui sont faites de gaz
Du coup ces planètes elles ont pas une surface bien définie, ces planètes gazeuses.
Donc c'est pas un endroit où on pourrait aller se poser
et construire un truc.
Pour ça il faut une planète rocheuse.
Alors le problème, c'est que les planètes gazeuses
sont en général beaucoup plus grosses
et donc elles sont beaucoup plus faciles à détecter
que les planètes rocheuses.
Et donc pendant longtemps,
les premières exoplanètes que l'on avait détectées
étaient des planètes très grosses, gazeuses
et donc pas du tout adaptées à l'idée
d'aller les coloniser par exemple.
Depuis quelques temps,
on arrive à détecter des planètes rocheuses
avec des tailles qui sont entre 1 et 10 fois
la taille de la Terre.
Et là on a une planète rocheuse dont la taille
est du même ordre de grandeur que celle de la Terre
Donc c'est vraiment quelque chose d'assez incroyable.
Ce qu'on sait d'autre sur cette planète,
c'est sa distance à son étoile.
Donc à Proxima du Centaure,
c'est une distance de 7 millions de kilomètres.
Alors 7 millions de kilomètres, c'est pas beaucoup.
À titre de comparaison,
nous on est à 150 millions de kilomètres du soleil,
donc elle est vraiment proche de son étoile.
Et intuitivement, on pourrait penser
que sur cette planète, ça doit être la fournaise.
En fait c'est pas le cas,
parce que Proxima du Centaure est une étoile
qui est beaucoup moins lumineuse que le soleil.
C'est ce qu'on appelle une naine rouge.
Et donc quand on fait le bilan,
on trouve que la température qui pourrait régner
à la surface de cette planète,
elle pourrait être du même ordre de grandeur
que la température qui règne sur Terre.
Comment on fait
pour détecter une exoplanète comme ça ?
Pour détecter une planète de ce genre,
ce qu'il faut savoir,
c'est que c'est pas par observation directe,
c'est pas genre on pointe un télescope sur l'étoile
et on voit la planète, ça ne se passe pas comme ça.
On fait une détection indirecte.
Il y a plusieurs manières de faire une détection indirecte.
Celle qui a été utilisée dans cette découverte,
c'est celle de la vitesse radiale
Pour comprendre ce que c'est,
il faut voir que quand on a une planète
qui tourne autour d'une étoile,
l'étoile bouge aussi un petit peu, car la force de gravité
agit dans les 2 sens : c'est à dire que la planète
exerce une petite influence sur l'étoile.
En fait c'est pas juste la planète
qui tourne autour de l'étoile,
C'est aussi l'étoile
qui peut avoir un petit mouvement de rotation
autour du centre de masse du système.
Cette légère oscillation de l'étoile, on peut la détecter.
C'est pareil, on ne la détecte pas directement,
on ne voit pas l'étoile bouger,
mais on la détecte avec ce qu'on appelle l'effet Doppler.
L'effet Doppler, vous connaissez peut-être, c'est ce qui se passe quand on a une voiture de pompier
qui vient vers nous et on entend le bruit de la sirène
qui est légèrement plus aigu
puis une fois qu'elle s'éloigne de nous,
le son est légèrement plus grave.
C'est dû à la compression
et à la dilatation des ondes sonores.
Il se passe à peu près la même chose avec la lumière,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet Doppler-Fizeau,
notamment quand vous avez une étoile
qui est légèrement en train de venir vers nous
le spectre de la lumière qu'elle émet
se décale légèrement vers le bleu
et quand elle s'éloigne,
il se décale légèrement vers le rouge.
Donc quand une étoile oscille comme ça
avec une petite rotation,
on peut détecter ça
en observant le spectre de l'étoile,
en observant la couleur de l'étoile
et en détectant des oscillations de cette couleur.
Donc pour ça il faut utiliser un type d'appareil,
qu'on appelle un spectromètre,
qu'on met sur un télescope
et qui permet de faire l'analyse de la lumière.
Je vais vous mettre une petite courbe
qui montre exactement
ce que les gens qui ont travaillé sur cette découverte ont vu.
c'est un exemple de ce qu'on peut mesurer.
il y a plusieurs choses intéressantes à noter
sur cette courbe.
La première chose, c'est ce qu'on voit là :
l'évolution de la vitesse radiale de l'étoile
en fonction du temps.
On voit que les vitesses radiales que l'on mesure
sont vraiment toutes petites.
C'est de l'ordre de quelques mètres par seconde.
c'est quand même assez incroyable
ce que je suis en train de vous dire,
C'est qu'on arrive à détecter des variations de vitesse
de l'ordre de quelques mètres par seconde
sur une étoile qui est quand même située
à 4 années lumières de nous.
C'est quand même assez spectaculaire.
Ce qu'on voit c'est que
l'oscillation, vous voyez que ça bouge,
mais c'est pas hyper clair.
Là, ce que je vous ai mis en rouge,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le fit,
C'est une courbe qui a une oscillation
qui passe bien par les points,
mais vous voyez que les données
ne sont pas hyper claires.
ça montre que pour détecter ce genre de choses,
il faut énormément de données.
là je ne vous ai donné qu'un petit extrait
des données totales.
Il faut énormément de données
pour être sûr de l'oscillation qu'on voit.
les astronomes ont utilisé des données
venant de différents télescopes
et qui ont été accumulées pendant les 16 dernières années, ça a commencé en 2000 jusqu'en 2016.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'ils ont dû utiliser
des données assez hétérogènes
qui venaient de différents télescopes
et qui ont été prises à différents moments
et en analysant ces données,
ils ont détecté cette espèce d'oscillation,
mais ce n'était pas encore suffisamment sûr
pour qu'ils aient le droit d'annoncer
la découverte de cette étoile.
Donc ils ont fait au début de l'année 2016 une nouvelle campagne de mesures vraiment spécifiques
centrées sur cette question, qui a duré 2 mois
et qui leur a permis de prouver
qu'il y avait cette oscillation.
Cette oscillation, on voit sur la courbe ici,
sa durée c'est à peu près 11 jours.
ça veut dire que l'étoile oscille
avec une période de 11 jours
et donc ça traduit le fait que la planète tourne autour avec une période de 11 jours.
vous voyez donc que l'année sur cette planète
durerait 11 de nos jours à nous.
Si vous vous amusez à regarder
la publication scientifique,
vous verrez qu'il y a énormément de personnes
qui ont collaboré pour en arriver là
et c'est notamment lié au fait qu'on a dû utiliser
plusieurs types de télescopes pour être sûr
de pouvoir confirmer cette découverte.
Parmi les auteurs de la publication,
il y a notamment un français
qui travaille au CNRS à Montpellier
qui s'appelle Julien Morin,
que je remercie parce qu'il m'a envoyé
quelques petites infos au sujet de la découverte.
Ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est qu'il y a d'autres personnes
qui ont travaillé sur les données liées à cette planète
et qui ont fait des publications séparées,
notamment pour essayer de comprendre
quel pouvait être le climat sur cette planète.
Qu'est-ce qu'on entend lorsqu'on dit que cette planète est peut-être habitable ?
il y a une chose qu'il faut avoir en tête, c'est qu'on se focalise principalement sur l'idée de la température,
mais pour juger si une planète est habitable ou pas,
il n'y a évidemment pas que la température.
il y a l'atmosphère, la présence, ou pas, de rayons UV,
de rayons X etc.
des tas de choses qui peuvent aller contre le fait
qu'une planète soit habitable.
mais on commence par regarder la température,
et généralement on considère que
il faut que la température soit de l'ordre de grandeur
e ce qu'il faut pour avoir de l'eau liquide,
si on part du principe que l'eau liquide est un pré requis
pour abriter la vie, même si c'est pas forcément le cas,
j'en avais parlé dans une vidéo précédente.
On peut essayer d'estimer la température
qui règne sur cette planète, comment on fait ?
on connaît sa distance à l'étoile
et on connaît aussi la puissance de l'étoile,
la puissance intrinsèque de l'étoile.
donc on peut calculer la quantité d'énergie
que cette planète reçoit
et estimer sa température de "corps noir".
la température de corps noir de cette planète,
c'est -40°C.
ça peut paraître froid comme ça,
mais il faut savoir que la température de corps noir
c'est pas exactement la vraie température.
à titre de comparaison,
la température de corps noir de la Terre, c'est - 18°C
alors que la température moyenne, c'est à peu près 14°C.
l'écart entre les deux dans le cas de la Terre
est dû à l'effet de serre,
j'en avais parlé dans ma vidéo
sur le réchauffement climatique.
c'est grâce à l'effet de serre
que la température qui y règne n'est pas -18°C,
mais quelque chose de plus important que ça.
donc suivant l'atmosphère qu'il peut y avoir, ou pas,
et la présence, ou pas, d'un effet de serre,
il est possible que la température soit supérieure
à la température de corps noir.
en tout cas une température de coprs noir de -40°C,
on considère que c'est pas mal
parce que c'est quelque chose qui serait à priori
dans la gamme qu'on recherche pour avoir éventuellement une planète habitable.
Comme toujours avec ce genre d'annonce,
il faut être un peu prudent.
La découverte en elle même, c'est du solide,
il y a plusieurs campagnes de mesures
qui ont été destinées à essayer de recouper les données pour être sûr que ce qu'on avait là
était vraiment une exoplanète,
et notamment une question était de savoir si
cette oscillation mesurée de 11 jours
n'était pas due simplement à l'étoile elle-même.
et donc des campagnes spécifiques ont été faites
pour s'assurer que ce facteur pouvait être écarté
et que c'était vraisemblablement une exoplanète.
Par contre, sur la question de l’habitabilité,
il faut être prudent.
Une chose, c'est qu'on connaît la masse de la planète, mais on ne connaît pas sa taille
ce qui veut dire
qu'on ne connaît pas encore vraiment sa densité.
on suppose qu'avec une taille comme ça,
elle est certainement rocheuse,
mais on n'en est pas sûr à 100 %.
L'autre chose qu'il faut avoir en tête,
c'est qu'on parle de la masse de la planète.
si on regarde bien la publication,
c'est pas vraiment sa masse,
c'est ce qu'on appelle sa masse minimale,
c'est à dire que l'estimation de la masse qu'on fait
dépend de l'angle d'inclinaison
entre l'orbite de la planète et notre ligne de visée,
c'est à dire que la masse minimale
qui a été calculée à 1,3 fois la masse de la Terre,
ça suppose que la planète tourne dans un plan
qui est dans la ligne de visée de l'étoile.
si elle a une orbite un peu inclinée,
sa masse réelle sera supérieure
à la masse minimale qu'on a estimée,
mais ce sera probablement
dans le même ordre de grandeur.
En conclusion, personnellement,
je trouve que cette découverte est assez extraordinaire.
C'est vrai que les exoplanètes,
on en entend souvent parler.
ça fait un peu plus de 20 ans qu'on sait les détecter
puisque la première exoplanète
qui a été découverte autour d'une étoile, c'était en 1995
et aujourd'hui, on en a détecté plus de 3000,
donc ça peut devenir un peu banal.
Et puis il est vrai que généralement
quand on en parle dans la presse,
c'est plutôt pour nous annoncer des trucs du genre :
"On a trouvé une exoplanète avec 2 soleils,
un peu comme Tatooine"
J'étais devenu un peu insensible à ce genre de choses,
Mais là je dois dire que je trouve ça assez fascinant
de se dire qu'il y a une exoplanète
autour de Proxima du Centaure
qui est l'étoile la plus proche de nous
à part le Soleil.
et c'est fou de penser qu'aujourd'hui
on n'est pas du tout capable de faire du voyage stellaire
et je ne sais pas quand on sera capable de le faire,
mais de penser que
le jour où on saura faire le voyage stellaire,
ce sera très probablement peut-être
la première destination vers laquelle on essayera d'aller
et cette planète vient d'être découverte.
Personnellement, je trouve ça vraiment enthousiasmant
et j'espère que ce sera la même chose pour vous.
Merci, à bientôt.